let's jump to the first story from the
San Francisco Chronicle what we know
about David de Pape man accused of
attacking Paul Pelosi with a hammer
first and foremost the story is he broke
into the house I believe it was in the
wee hours of the morning screaming
where's Nancy it's what they've reported
and then mercilessly beat Paul Pelosi
with a hammer I mean it's deranged and
unhinged but many people are trying to
figure out what the motivations of this
man was of course immediately people on
the right were saying sounds like crime
it's San Francisco why would we assume
otherwise I think that's logical many on
the left said clearly it's Republicans
it's Maga this is what they want for you
well they were wrong it turns out he
listed himself as a member of the green
party voting records showed de Pape
listed himself as a member of the green
party years ago so this is not somebody
who just had on his profile it's not
it's not the media just claiming it it's
actually in his records green party yo
green party is leftist